welcome back you've seen him on The
Tonight Show Jimmy Fallon Comedy Central
Conan and now you can see him perform
right here in Las Vegas joining us today
we have comedian Tom takar Tom thank you
so much for being here thank you so much
for having me I'm so excited to be here
so I looked on your website and it says
Tom's car comedian or criminal should I
be nervous what does that mean I just
thought that would be a fun little
attention-grabbing thing for my little
website and you know it's it's it makes
me easier to find if I'm a criminal you
know where to find me you know I love it
it made me laugh out loud I was like I
have to ask him about that so you're
performing at the Comedy Cellar which is
so much fun out here at the Rio so what
can we expect from here so where do you
kind of pull inspiration from all over
the place I talk about what happened
that day I'll probably talk tonight
about how I really upset a man last
night playing craps I have lost a man a
lot of money and I felt bad I was
rolling and he was like you got to roll
with confidence and I was like I don't
know what that means but here's a seven
um well maybe the more that you perform
out here in Vegas you'll learn the
etiquette for craps or you know it's
kind of fun to you know get into the
gambling world but we're uh we're so
excited that you're out here you were
just telling me that you did a
cross-country road trip you're from New
York and you you made the way out to LA
right it was great it was better I
usually I drove this time it was either
that or fly on Spirit Airlines and I
decided to drive I usually fly spirit
and you have a bit on spirit I do yeah I
love it I'm trying to get sponsored by
them but they're going out of business I
think hey maybe you can help lift their
business I'm trying to get the word out
every time you should be the face of
their brand
there you are speaking up that's great
um so what can people expect when they
come to the show I mean do you have a
certain style or something to pride
yourself on I like to talk about my
family I'm from Indiana I'm from the
Midwest I talk a lot about that I a lot
of my family's trash I talk about them I
talk about how dangerous Indiana is like
I grew up I say that uh that it's I grew
up the main form of entertainment in my
hometown was a trampoline that didn't
have the guard and that thing around it
and it was like little kid Vietnam yeah
kids hobble away like oh we lost Jeremy
back there you know uh and my brother
broke his leg on our trampoline
immediately because he was like I'm
gonna go as high as I can on the new
trampoline and then he did to protect
him he's had nothing there so he started
floating away from the trampoline I
don't know if you know that moment where
you see somebody suspended in the air
but you're like oh no we're about to
hear new noise
well Tom congratulations on everything
we're so excited to have you performing
out here in Vegas now that you're in L.A
you're close you'll have to come back I
can't wait all right well we'll come see
you at The Comedy Cellar at the Rio be
sure to check out Tom show thank you so
much for being here thanks so much
Mercedes